you're different  sooner or later different scares people  you think if you don't fight back then  maybe they'll like him stop picking on  you calling you freaking  victim or not  make a decision  your son as a remarkable young man  and wouldn't surprise me if he has more  in common with Einstein Mozart and  Picasso than he does with us  he has highly advanced cognitive skills  the obsessive personality  can our son lead a normal life  define normal  maybe he's capable much more than we  know  say you're the head of the Sinaloa  cartel who can you trust a director  stolen cash he's capable is coming in  cold on cooking years of books and  getting out alive  imagine the secrets this guy has who are  you  can our son lead a normal life define  normal  Oh  you've spent your life trying to widen  it